great you're done let me show you how I
implemented this one inside of detail
fragment with in detail activity first
of course we add a constant for the
loader I've also added a projection for
the columns I want to get from the
database and of course corresponding
constants then we have our detail
fragment implement our loader callbacks
for cursor loader of course with
parameterised type cursor in oncreate
loader we create a new cursor loader for
the URI that came in from the intent in
on load finished I format a string to
math what was in the original forecast
fragment and set it to the M forecast
variable as well as the textview we
don't have to do anything with onload or
reset because there isn't any data that
we were holding on to that needs to be
cleaned up but how do we fix the share
intent I start by creating a member
variable for the share action provider I
set this variable and on create options
menu only if we have a forecast we don't
make any assumptions about the order in
which our loader happens finally an
onload finished I set the share intent
this will update the share action
provider if it already exists let's make
sure this still works the list is we
would expect it to be and when we click
on one of these we get the detailed view
we even have a share action provider and
as you can see we can share it and
there's our forecast